all right check check
chicken charlie
charlie cheese chimpanzee
charlie chaplin
the chimpanzee
chocolate chip
chuckling
[Music]
those are all chill words a lot of time
if you're doing
microphone audio
if they if you communicating through a
microphone or a
you know somebody you got a man
listening somewhere or a woman
or a lesbian
a lot of time they'll say can you give
me a sound check
and people will say mike check charlie
check charlie they want to
chu sounds
they want a certain sound a certain
sound
i guess a certain sound does a certain
thing
a certain sound lets you know it's a
certain
[Music]
siren it's a certain
warning
a certain sound
you know i make a certain sound
different times like if uh
if i
if i'm looking for something i can't
find it
if i'm if i if i'm i went out to the car
and i got in it and i do not have
something i need i have to go back
inside
jesus
christ
and that's when look
i could have never been jesus christ
dude he had to walk all those stairs or
whatever with the um
i don't even know what he had like a
big piece of furniture on his back or
something i don't even know i got to
reread it but
uh
i couldn't
dude
i'll leave anything inside and he did
like a thousand steps or something
i'll leave anything inside
i
literally would rather
eat one of my own nuts out of my uh
nut bag than
i have to go back in and get it
but i'd be like
that's a sound i make sometimes
and i'll go back and have to unlock the
door i'm like
oh
then i will i will yell where are where
where are you where
where would you put that
i will yell at myself so even
and it's something small usually like my
dang
it could be i got a new cbd vapor it's
cbd it's vaping but it's non-addictive
and
uh
it's laser lime
so that's where i'm at mentally and
emotionally but that's a sound you know
a different sound is something that
comes out of a different thing
[Applause]
trying to think when i would make that
sound yeah
oh
that's if you're changing a diaper or
something you get duty on you or
something
or if you touch duty somewhere
my friend used to do this trick
and uh
and he passed away but he uh
when he was alive he used to do this
little
little kind of [ __ ] trick
i guess you would call it and i don't
want to be
unprofessional or whatever but it would
be like a little
he'd say hey man catch and he'd have a
little dog
little duty in his hand little [ __ ]
a dog had done a little uh little turd
work or whatever
a little booty little booty [ __ ] and he
would
be like hey hey bud you left this and
he'd say something like that
and throw it over to you
and you'd catch it you didn't know what
it was
and uh
it was something that had come out of a
dog's
bottom usually
usually fessies or something but anyway
um
man good to be here with you guys today
and i'm really i'm feeling good today
and i'm grateful you're here
and i want to thank um i want to remind
you to support the netflix special it's
out now you can check it out
uh it's on netflix channel platform
so you can see it get on there
i've been meaning to watch also made
on there
um but i haven't seen that yet
um
and
yeah i'm glad it's out i'm glad that
it's done um
you know it was tough because the
material was ready a few years ago
and then
the uh
the pandemic and so there's been this
real
but it's like everything supply chain
that's what they call it
dude the other day i'm trying to buy
some cupcake
and i said hey man let me get a couple
halloween uh
little cupcakes off you you know what
i'm saying the guy back there honestly
i'm not going to say it's
it's a gay guy working back there
and as a straight guy it's
i'm grateful that the guy is selling
cupcakes i'm grateful anybody's selling
them
the fact that somebody even thought of
saying hey let's take a big cake and
make it small
so daddy could have him a little sugar
at lunch
god that makes me oh
that that that's the sound i make when i
hear that oh
that sort of jewish ejaculation sort of
oh
but
i want to talk about
oh yeah it's just tough and then the
guy's like i just want to tell you know
we've had a lot of supply chain issues
with the food coloring
and i'm like dude
dude i will literally poke my gums with
a needle and spit in that white frosting
right now
i do that three times we will get it to
orange
and you can i see he was just making
conversation and i i i start to see how
women feel
about men hitting on them
because you can't even find a woman
working the cupcake area anymore
it's a lot of men on men you know
it's a lot of sugar boys back there
and i'm here for it i support it i mean
you know i want everybody
to live their best life but and then the
guy's like well let me go
let me get your number and i'll let you
know if we have anything coming in like
dude
i don't need uh some guy texting me at
night
saying we got
you know green
you know i'm saying we got all the fall
colors like i'm not trying to roll over
in my bed
and get that
hey just got a little you know
don't want to alarm you just got a
little you know
just got a little visine thing full of
yellow you know what i'm saying like
just
it just
but that's life life is that full circle
life's that full circle man
you kick a ball in a handicapped kid
40 years later bro
he'll stab you with a knife at a damn uh
at a um what's that place called
piccadilly cafeteria
that's
that's how it works
so
oh
there's i like mad this it's just
different sounds you make god wear a lot
i like the different sounds that we have
in us there's a lot of them
you know
[Music]
if you if you pet a dog and he don't
walk off god i love that
god i love that
if if you pet a dog
and he stay right there and let you do
it
god
you turn into a dang pedophile baby you
know what i'm saying boy
you get that wowzer on that schnauzer
baby
um
you just he keeps letting you do it you
get that little
um that glishon on that vichon baby
that is when god that's when you feel
god working when you pet a dog
a strange dog a miscellaneous dog baby
and it let you keep petting
[Music]
oh make you want to kick a fat kid at
kmart you know what i'm saying praise
god baby um
but i just want to say thank you for
supporting me in comedy so and i am glad
that that we got the show on the air now
and you can see where you watch netflix
on your phone or whatever
and tell your friends tell your wife
you know what i'm saying they're ripping
everybody out here
um
all right let's get into it baby let's
get into it got a nice episode for you
here today and uh i'm happy to be alive
and i'm happy you're alive
and i mean that and if nobody's told you
that today boom
somebody has
[Music]
we got our boy eddie 9 volts
about to get electrocuted
[Music]
um
well i just broke up with my baby
[Music]
he's gonna come up
and that right there
that right there is eddie 9v on the come
up
oh that song lifts me i feel lifted
i feel lifted
i want to thank david freeze
for this beautiful jersey man
you know the st louis cardinals they let
me out there on a ball game on a ball
game field
and i'm bad luck usually on a ball game
field
you put me in the game you lose or
somebody gets damn
you know asthma attacks i remember they
put me in a game once and five kids had
asthma attacks
and the police showed up and somebody
busted some woman for having um
you know fake handicapping a kid that
sometimes they used to
they make one of the kids be [ __ ] or
mentally ill
just to get that money that dummy check
you would see it a lot in the poor
community a lot of the urban community
you'd see him have a child that they
didn't let go to school
and they keep him out of school so he
don't learn anything
but every now and then you know and
since he don't know anything he he he
get that check 600 a month 300 i think
at the time
and uh
they put a neck brace on him every now
and then wheel him out to a sporting
event or something so people in town
could see him whoever it was or her
you know when the kid out there they
have
you know one time the damn
it's usually like foster parents
sometimes
but sometimes it's people's own parents
you know family they say look we're not
doing that good
we ain't making much money we got four
or five kids
let's keep one of them away from the
school and put that neck brace on them
and they wheel them out on a dolly to
daddy sometime i remember wheeling this
one kid out
you know this boy long they call him
long tommy because he
he was long getting long as hell he
you could barely see him if he tickled
his foot it took probably
four seconds for him to know
you know what was happening for him to
get even a giggle out of them
so you could damn you know you could
almost burn off one of his toes if you
know if you were really cruel
and i wasn't
you know i'm grateful to god for that i
didn't have that cruelty where i'm
burning
burning children's
tarsals or whatever
but um
what was i talking about oh but the
daddy sometime would wheel him out there
on a damn dolly a damn you know
home depot dolly and just prop him out
so people in the community could see him
oh they still got him he's alive
you know
and then uh that was just part of the
whole deal and then you get the money
for 350 a month i think it went up to
almost 400 dollars when i was young
now i don't now they give you money for
anything
you know what i'm saying somebody
patting you on the back too hard to give
you seventy dollars eighty dollars
you know
somebody you know spray painted uh
you know uh [ __ ] on your car or
something to give you
you know
government give you to give you 75 bucks
60 60
dollars so different times uh
but what i'm saying is he gave me this
real jersey from the world
series dude
not poker either i'm talking the real
one baby that big one
and uh and that's awesome man it's just
so nice of them to be so gifting like
that and
and the cardinals made a beautiful run
this year and they didn't get it done
and uh
so anyway i just wanted to show some
homage to them into saint louis
that was a loud show that st louis show
damn
if you were at that thing
there were people somebody people
gestating in the back
some lady back there uh
you know just people loud in the
audience
somebody having a real a violent uh
menstrual cycle you hear
i mean just really i mean just
damn full moon and right out of her damn
vagina
just a dark art and
people in there people with damn
some dude had a uh something stuck in
his throat up kazoo or something for
half the show you just hear
damn what is even going on in here
but
but still grateful people came out
there's been a lot of good shows
recently i i haven't seen you guys in a
while uh on a solo episode um
and so i wanted to come this week and
make sure we got one in
uh
you know what's been happening we went
to wilkes bar
and dams oh i get into town some guy
give me a uh
railroad tie
a piece of iron
i'm eating i'm outside having me a
little sandwich out there
about a thoroughfare
out there and this actually this was in
uh delaware
in delaware dude if you want to
if you want to see people fist fighting
um
and nobody wins
then you gotta go to
wilmington delaware's baby uh
delaware delaware i don't know what
that's spanish for
where i'm gonna look that up
what does where mean in
english
pottery
de la pottery so the day of pottery
uh
the day of pottery i guess it means well
damn whoever
there was a lot of bulls in the china
shop because there was a lot of broken
[ __ ] around there but um
good area though uh
he was good at good good area good
people good people that came out
um
a lot of diversity came out everybody's
damn you know
uh damn judeo
uh
african italian a tau yerman they gotta
you know
italianese everybody's african it's how
germany's out there it's all damn you
know
everybody
has a twin that's been killed it's just
a there's a lot of um
you're not surprised to have a weapon
and some man gave me a weapon
he came up i'm having me a little burger
right there on a thoroughfare
and a thoroughfare everybody in the
place at the burger place was in a uh i
think it was a halfway house they said
it closed at 8 p.m because people had to
sign in or whatever
so gratefully they were making food um
but i was happy to be there i made a
good time
up in that piece
uh
but a man gave me a
one of them railroad ties real fast here
you go you're gonna need this sharpened
up too fellow named buck i think his
name was or
he could have had a lisp his name could
have honestly been [ __ ] bro
[ __ ] you know
oh
god oh
so i don't remember what it was but
that was crazy wilkes-barre was one of
the best shows i feel like i've ever had
in my life
and that was fun
i don't know where we were we got there
to reservation only place to stay in
town is a damn holiday inn or whatever
and it says when they get there they say
there's signs everywhere say people will
steal from me here
i am you know your company's having a
tough time if they putting that [ __ ] up
but
it was holiday in select
and i don't know what they selected man
they must have
it must have been a draft at a local
prison bro because everybody everybody
in that [ __ ] was i felt like an inmate
you know you could hear the guy behind
the counter every time he walked over to
the printer to print out the thing or
whatever you could hear his shackles on
it i'm like jesus
i might even go to sleep here i'd rather
i'm gonna stay in the car and sharpen
this railroad tie
um
but that was a joy man all the shows
joyous
where were we this week honestly i do
not someplace i don't even just go so
fast you know you go and uh
oh minneapolis
and we interviewed jesse ventura that'll
come out this coming uh next week
jesus christ i hope no one ever has to
i respect this time i hope no one ever
has to on honestly uh
speak to that man
that's what i hope um
what else
uh
oh dave chappelle special came on
and i watched it
and
obviously
you know he's a legend he's made his way
up being legendary and
i thought there was definitely a lot of
funny parts he's a funny guy obviously
he's created his own way of doing comedy
it's his own
ambiance it's his own thing
um
the parts for me that were a little
rocky were
uh
he you know kind of referred to himself
as the goat i thought some of the
i've noticed his ego has kind of been
real sprouting over the years
you know even just the way he comes
coming to the comedy club and um
[Music]
but i don't know if it's possible for it
not to
you know we live in a world where
there's so much reflection of yourself
that i think it's hard to hide from your
ego
because now with social media and
everything your ego has weapons
your ego has
there's so many ways for your ego to
communicate back with you and tell you
you're
good or you're this or you're popular or
you're seen or you're whatever you know
back in the day your ego i mean
it definitely had internal weapons
making you think you're great or making
you
you know
behave certain types of ways or if you
start chiefing on your own [ __ ]
that's what my uncle used to say bro
and he actually died dude he got i
didn't tell you guys this my mom's
original brother
got killed he was alcoholic got hit by a
um
i'm not hit by he got killed by a
train
motocross train or whatever
track train
you know not three people [ __ ] you
know ran into him or whatever
um
but
i wasn't even talking about but anyway
yeah i thought it definitely some of
that part where you were referring to
yourself as a goat that's a weird moment
uh
to watch
as a human
um
but i i don't care what he's i mean i
feel like he got kind of stuck on this
transgender discussion thing over the
years which i don't really understand
but i feel like also once you've gotten
so many things out of the world you have
all the cash and prizes what else is
there to even
you know a lot of rich people will end
up being uh
gay
or money gays they call them
and
it's like the roman empire
at the end they're upstate you know i'm
saying they're upstairs
they're upstairs eating freaking newborn
cabbages and
making love to damn
straight and gay children and men and
women
because they'd done everything that
exhausted all the options of
of
their desires their desire because
desire is that little leap frog
you give you start off you give him a
little butter scotch baby
and next thing you know he's hopping you
know he'll hop over to a damn cupcake
two days later
and then he's hopping to a birthday
party
and now he's at a damn uh
crown plaza
you know he's at a damn barbecue at a
for you know an urban kind of family
reunion or whatever and two people get
shot
um
but
but then he'll jump you know next thing
you know he's at the jewelry store he's
at a tyler the creator concert
and you know he'll just ke you know
it just keeps escalating whatever it is
that desire
desire will keep escalate
so once you've done everything the
romans were doing i mean it got real
dicey what they were doing
you know uh
and i just think that's what happens to
someone as you get to a certain level
it's just there's nothing left to do
so you're sitting around you're chatting
about trans and people that are trans
and what's going on
um
i did like that netflix supported him
and let him say what he wants to say he
should be people should be able to
that all that [ __ ] is ridiculous and
nobody even really cares the only people
that care honestly i think a bunch of
people that just
i don't know people that are trying to
stifle ever all the communication
some people the only thing they have to
go for going for them i think is their
sexuality or their
whatever their little difference is
and those sometimes are the people that
make their difference a bigger deal
people yelling look i'm different don't
treat me different
that's the you know
and it also could be a part of the times
we're going through but i'm glad he got
to say what he wanted to say man i i
definitely laughed out loud a few times
um
he's one of a kind and uh and those are
my thoughts on uh some of my thoughts on
the dave chappelle special i don't get
to have a you know it's hard for me to
have a lot of thoughts at once but i
just tried
so
um
what else
oh
i'm trying to think of anything else
that's been going on we got some great
calls that came in
um
you know i want to let you know that uh
that um
blue chew you know i take them
i took one the other night oh i gotta
tell you this
let me do the ad first and i'll tell you
so blue chew you know what it is
your body ain't working you can't get
that rudder baby you know what i'm
saying
you can't get you know what i'm saying
you can't get that you can't put a
ripple in the water
because you rudders down oh god oh god
rudder down
i'm downstairs
blue chew it's a unique online service
they deliver the same active ingredients
as viagra cialis and they are hitters
dog
and i'm that cheapy boy
i'm that cheapy boy dude i'll get me a
balloon nibble off a corner
i'm on a date it's going good i'll
nibble off a third it's going bad i'll
just have a quarter
just to you know
because i want to feel that pump later
even if i'm by
myself it's going
i'll never eat a whole one gee birds
what
oh my god you see do you see a couple
gay dudes in the park spinning me like a
top bro
spinning me on that freaking uh on that
nutted tip you feel me at wiener
blue chew they do it they do it right
they do uh they do it right bluetooth
tablets are made in the usa so you get
that real fortified straight out of
detroit weiner you're going to love it
try blue true free when you use our
promo code t-h-e-o at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w
dot com promo code theo to receive your
first month free and we thank bluechu
for sponsoring this podcast they work
and they're damn tasty that's a problem
you'll have a third and one you're like
damn this thing tastes good next thing
you know you had two thirds
you know what i'm saying the next thing
you know you crushing it up and you
rubbing it on your damn gums bruh that's
dicey so praise god
i gotta let you know about this you know
we've been looking for artwork recently
for uh some i'm upstairs merch
and if you have some uh neat ideas you
can email those in and we'll put the
link for the uh tpw producer
um
but one way to find uh help online if
you need dynamic help
it's called fiverr yep
fiverr and we we got some designs off of
there we didn't we
they weren't favorites the ones that we
got that's why i'm mentioning it to you
guys but you can get them there you can
get everything there
fiverr
is a global network of on-demand
freelance talent
and it's here to help whether you're
launching your first business
scaling
your current business scaling that hoe
up
or if you in need of support
from graphic design copywriting
marketing web programming film editing
scoring music and more
find your talent and begin working on
your project within minutes anything you
need it's easy customize your search by
service deadline price seller reviews
emaci
all these beans are good
all these pins are good
that's it fiverr
f-i-v-e-r-r.com code theo
yup find a freelancer with the specific
skills you need quit asking your but hey
do you know somebody that [ __ ] doesn't
work
check out f-i-v-e-r-r dot com and
receive 10 off your first order by using
code
t-h-e-o all the digital services in one
place f-i-v-e-r-r-dot-com
code theo
it's a great service
really is a great stock if you bought it
a few years ago really boomed out
you could have bought yourself something
about your little son
what else man um
after the show sometimes i've been able
to pop out and do some uh meet and
greets and surprise some folks we're not
surprised but just say hey to you guys
um
sometimes some nights it's harder than
others some venues don't allow it
um
you know minneapolis was tough because
they made it was the first venue i've
been to where they made them wear masks
and
[Music]
i didn't know it until halfway through
the first show i'm like what's going on
i'm not i just i'm not
good at this anymore
you know or maybe everybody's
maybe everybody ate something real hot
in the lobby and their mouth is burning
or that everybody ate a
dorito and cut the top of their mouth
because i couldn't hear any laughter
and then halfway through i'm like oh my
gosh everybody has to have masks in here
and that is honestly
ridiculous
and thank you for the people that came
and put up with it
it's not my choice when we sold the
tickets none of those things were my
choice um
but it's tough because like what do you
do you cancel the show some of these
people are just putting these things
into place
i think it's absolutely insane
you know i live in a place uh most of
the time
in the central east here where
people are unmasked and everybody is
doing fine and well
and
there's no logical you can't explain to
me how you one play it just
so and i'm not here to debate it with
nobody
i know
that
covet is dangerous i believe that
but
i don't know that people should have
mass inside of a damn venue that's
unbelievable
and uh
and that's sad
and i hope to not put any more venues on
the schedule where that's what's going
on so that is one thing that i'm going
to try my best to do but thank you guys
who came and buried with it
and some people
they said well you
you can't be doing the thing you're at
the dude well i'm sorry
it's the best i can do right now some
places all the venues are owned by the
same company
it's like a youtube but it's like a
property management you know
so you're just kind of screw you're just
it's really tough man to feel very free
but know that when you feel that way i
feel that way too
and so i'm hoping that things change
usually
when something needs to change
something does
so
uh
what else
i think that's all i got right now i
just wanted to keep you guys informed
keep you guys tuned in we got some great
voicemails that came in
as always the hotline is 985-664-9503
um
yeah you know i've been struggling i've
still been struggling a lot with anger
i've been trying to go to more aaa
meetings and do more meditation
uh today's the best i've felt in a while
um
battling that
uh
and i don't know if i find i get angry
at
any one specific thing really i just
i just get angered man
it's like the dynamite is in my it's
right under my skin bro
man it wants me to be a it's like
something wants me to be angry
and i can notice it's bad when i wake up
in a couple of uh
one of the the first few things i thank
her is that i'm angry
or i get angry about certain things
so
um
yeah i guess i just want to say that out
loud so i'm not just letting it be
inside of me
sometimes if i let things just stay
inside of me and i don't say them out
loud then it's like they win
you know and i wish you know i've even
been asking my anger why are you here
what do you want
cause sometimes it does feel like a it's
like a ghost of something that happened
or a ghost of some
desires i don't know what it just feels
like a thing that's just like
it's almost feel like it's haunting me
and that sounds crazy not in the sense
like
you know like there's a damn uh
exorcism or something sneaking in my ear
at night
and busting big nuts
but just like a
i don't know
sometimes i feel like there's an
infection in me
and it's anger
uh
but anyway we got some beautiful calls
that came in man enough about me
something i feel like dana's podcast is
about me so much it's just too much
so i want to hear from you guys thank
you for hitting the hotline 985-664-9503
um
[Music]
all right here we go
hi theo this is katie
i am a mechanical engineer in south
carolina i'm coming to both of your
charleston shows i'm very excited
so katie
and that mechanical but you know you
that little
mechanical bad girl huh
that lego lady huh
you out there just using you know
you out there using that little monkey
wrench
banana around probably on some of these
i'm sure
thank you for calling baby onward
calling to tell you about a recent
experience i had
my dad he hasn't really wanted me to
date really want me to have grandkids
blah blah blah
so he says hey katie you know i got this
perfect guy for you i got skies great
guy good christian man
you know he's real nice oh yeah
and a child is like a little fireplace
for your family
your family hate each other your family
be shooting damn arrows at each other
and doing heroin
and somebody have a baby and good god
people will stop doing heroin at least
in the daytime to be around that kid
together
and
that's that's god
onward
yes guys great guy good christian man
you know he's real nice he works with me
i said okay dad
i'll give him a try so we're texting you
know it's fine he has to go on a date i
think okay cool he's gonna meet for
lunch make some lunch
uh old boy brings his cousin
so it was uh me and two men
whoo boy
oh
i went
dang
that little side kick kinda he brought
that side item
he brought that little i guess if you
didn't like him they want they're ready
to you know this family's ready to bust
overall somebody about to catch a gonad
full
somebody about to get naded out
and get that procreation going on them
biblical dogs they don't care
you know what i'm saying if freddy ain't
your fit
then we got little uh frankie right here
on the side step
we got you know what i'm saying if you
don't like ernie as that entree
then we got little uh that little side
item sammy right here he'll get in there
and he'll nut around until somebody has
something to uh
to uh to give birth to let's hear more
so it is paid for
but one of the strangest dates i've had
but i think from this experiment
um
i've learned i could have two boyfriends
i think i would be okay with two men
um they even could be related i don't
think i would mind that
um it's just
two boyfriends i think would be good
double
double the fun really
what you think about it uh let me know
have a good one
see you uh two weekends bye
oh wow i took a turn oh
um
look these days
we're in corvette times we're in the
last chapter of the bible i feel like
and i don't know what it is ephesians or
whatever
you know i don't even know you know i'm
not even sure what's back there
i think it's just a damn tat it's like a
inventory
of how many men and how many sheep were
in the whole book but where this is the
end
you know people aren't even clocking in
for work anymore
the only people even working are mexican
i mean look you know
we're at the end i was just in
minneapolis there's nobody even in the
city anymore
everything's desert there's murals
everywhere
you achieved it you achieve maximum
diversity there's nobody there
they should call it minneapolis
because there ain't anybody in that
batch
so
this is the end of time baby if you want
to get that double up
get that family make a game show out of
your vagina i would
you know what i'm saying
let each of them boys take that chance
at that procreation
maybe do it you know
and at least you're gonna achieve your
grandfather's goals or whatever by
giving them that little papoose
and look a lot of us we just want
somebody to love it doesn't matter what
form it comes in or how it comes
you know a life i think if you can be
honest with your your partner about it
but the pro there's a there's certainly
a new age of people that's more about
polyamory
and
polygamous
and they'll let you do whatever
if you want to have a little bit of oreo
over here
if you want to have a little choco taco
but you want to also
you know get a little bit of uh these
butternutters over there you could do it
all you know i'm saying you could hide
an eminem in your ass if you want
and the whole time be skittling under
your tongue
people doing it all and it's i think as
long as everybody there's not as much
jealousy maybe
i grew up in the real jealousy era
where you saw somebody talk are you
talking to them as oh man
no
no ronda
but that's chain hours too you know
if somebody will feed ronda for tonight
you welcome to take her off of my hands
baby how are we doing upstairs that's
that upstairs cam
so it's a lot of there's definitely more
sharing is caring that's really come a
long way
you know um
a friend of mine said her her daughter
is getting taken care of half the time
by her grandmother
and at first i thought man that's a
little might be messed up but
then i thought well
that's how it probably used to be people
live and how the whole family's in there
you go to korea you can you flush the
toilet you'll drown one of your damn
cousins or whatever everybody's in the
damn
the whole everybody's in the house
you open up the top of a shipper robe
and you you know your great uncle's in
there
you know when he's on he's almost
deceased but he's also
covered in socks
so he's warm
but it's like the whole family sticks
together and it's more of a tribal thing
so
i like it
and also shout out to the date for
bringing kazo along huh
talk about being a wing man
talking that's like a buffalo wild wing
man
and watch them steal that and make that
if that isn't they might already have
that as a wingman i bet they do
as an advertiser piece but
but yeah you look
stay alert stay alarmed
somebody gave me a damn shiv the other
night before my own show when i was
having a little sandwich at a halfway
house
so if you don't think we on the last
notch at a belt
if you don't think this buckle's about
to bust
then you don't know nothing
about a 35 inch waist homie gang
thank you for calling katie
yeah who knows look
two men yeah
but you're gonna i wonder if y'all split
that check three ways that's what i
wondered
if y'all thriced up that check
yeah
that's interesting
dude if i'd have been on a date and some
lady brings her freaking
cousin i got twice the chances of a day
of of of meeting somebody
over one dinner
i'm having one blt but i got double the
chances of some tit there's four tits at
the table
i'm hoping milk for dessert you know
what
uh let's get another call that came in
here we go oh this one right here
what's up theo uh this is john from
maryland
i just got a question for you i wanted
to see what your views on
monogamy are um just
with everything going on nowadays seems
like it's a lot less than it used to be
and uh
i don't know i don't know if i
feel like it's going to be a part of my
generation i just wanted to get your
thoughts on that uh love you man thanks
for everything looking forward to seeing
you in charlotte gang gang buzz buzz
gang brother wow
and i was in charlotte and so i'm sure
we saw each other there and uh
and that was cool man so thank you for
coming i hope it was a good show
um
some nights i felt like they're good and
some nights i felt like they're not
honestly that's just me
they're all i know it's like i give it
them all every time but some nights
they're
you know me i mean jeepers i just
if i was if i enjoyed things we wouldn't
even have this show
so but i did just crack opening with
damn worthless boy
hmm
they are good
huh um
you have enough worthless man you start
dating a sister i think
very good i'm gonna set it down because
i know it
the sound of it is an ideal for some of
you
um you know i i think it's interesting
that monogamy is becoming less of a
thing
i believe it
because i think you're you're you're
getting
marriages they're not because people
want to have some freedom they want to
be able to
sneak around a pine tree
and blow somebody out or touch
somebody's [ __ ] or whatever
you know these kids are doing i don't
know
i'm not around children when they're
sexual
um
but yeah people want to just be able to
explore
people want to be able to explore and
before there was shows about like they
had cheaters you know
when they got that jewish italian dude
or whatever and they stabbed him on the
boat
because big adrian is uh you know
he's out there
you know
just boarding down some thick guys wife
or something at a wedding or what you
saw the [ __ ]
uh
but
but yeah and they used to have they had
the don you know uh
phil donahue's or whatever ricky lake
they had all these wendy william or the
um what's the guy's name
oh
not chucky
he's so i he's like oh
you could be the daddy that guy whatever
who's the dad
who is
and they bring up in the envelope and
it's like the it's i think it used to be
an advertisement for them ups or
whatever
but they're like stamps.com
you know
uh
sinclair you are the father
and then the the package or whatever is
from stamps.com but uh anyway so
i don't talk about um
man
uh
oh so that was the cheating was a big
thing it's like oh you cheated you
cheated you're mine you're mine this is
our thing this is and
everything is good it's getting more
swirly
we are beige bound i say that a lot on
here everything gonna end up beige
we're getting to the end you're seeing i
think the downside of
uh
the comforts of a capitalist of maybe
capitalist america i don't know that
i don't know enough knowledge
to know that
but we could be coming to the end of
you know every period of history has a
time
mesologic uh
game of thrones
dragons
uh
columbus
nasa
and what are we in now dude
i don't even know really freelance
so
you're seeing you know everything kind
of goes through its time and i think and
this could be what you know
i don't know do you guys think we're at
the end of times as far as like what
american society has been like do you
think or do you think we're just going
through a little transition period and
it's going to come out bigger and
brighter
um
what do you think on that i'm curious i
wonder sometimes is
you know
are we stuck in this
in this swipe society where we're just
we're literally just swiping for things
that we want
whether they're human or a human food
uh
instacart
insta heart where look at all of it is
is
we have access to it all
and so does it all lose its meaning when
it's
right there if you wake up with food in
your mouth man it's
then the part of you that wants to eat
it'll die i think
not the part of you that swallows the
food but the party that wants to eat
but more so the part of you that wants
to hunt
that's the scary thing
that's what i scared them i have one
more lick on this candy
they are good
glad i found that in my truck earlier
um
so those are some of my thoughts on it
man and i'd love to know what some of
you guys think what are some of your
thoughts on those types of things
985-664-9503 another call came in we got
a beautiful single mom that we're gonna
hit up at the end of today's show um
[Music]
you know my mom texted me yesterday and
just told me she was real proud of me
and that made me feel good
uh
i'm also going to tell you what's going
to help you keep your hair
that's keeps
you know so many men get rid of their
hair falls out falls into their tub
their shirt
dude i know how to buddy he would
collect all his hair in his bathroom and
dry it out on the counter and [ __ ] and
try to [ __ ] just kind of put it back
in his head on friday night
my friend jeremy dude and i respected it
but it was it was also kind of crazy so
but also
pretty decent guy he did online gaming
for a while and
and then his mom left him actually he
lived with his mother and she wouldn't
move out so she moved out
pretty cool miss martha pretty cool
okay but keeps
help you keep your hair it's a simple
stress-free way low-cost treatments
start at 10 a month
they offer generic versions discreet
packaging proven results
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months to see results so act
fast
you know i recently quit taking my hair
medicine
because i wanted to see if it was
causing some of the
pain i've been feeling
and uh and so i noticed a lot of my hair
thinned out you know
so these medicine stuff do work
so uh
just letting you know that they they do
work if you have to take them a lot
though uh you know you gotta take it you
gotta really
you really are slave to a pill
so
if you're ready to take action to
prevent hair losses go to keeps.com
keeps.com singular slash theo to get
your to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash t-h-e-o to get your first
month free keeps.com
[Music]
theo
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big wireless
providers if we've learned anything it's
that there's always a catch so when i
first heard that mint mobile offers
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month i thought
it all made sense there isn't one there
isn't a catch nope not with mint mobile
for people looking for extra savings
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15 bucks a month
it's a good deal
yep all plans come with unlimited talk
and text and high
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan and keep your same phone number
along with all your existing contacts
that easy
and if you're not 100 satisfied mint
mobile has you covered with a seven day
money back guarantee that's it that's a
deal yeah
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
theo that's mint mobile.com theo cut
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
mintmobile.com
theo
what else
let's get into it here
what's up ceo this is corbin uh what's
up corvin
obviously named after i'm guessing
probably a corvette and a
van
maybe
cool one of your parents was cool
and one of them drove a van
onward brother civil engineer in
great state of mississippi
um
oh dang
bro engineer y'all been engineering
civility over there huh
i haven't been there in a while i gotta
get back
but um
but thank you i can't imagine
engineering civility that seems
absolutely impossible but it seemed like
a vir vi
vibrant undertaking so thank you
for your service brother
i know you said to call in about uh what
scares us uh i think mine would be
getting old
you know i'm 25 right now uh
getting married coming down the pipe uh
and you know my hair is falling out
starting to pull some gray hairs uh
you know i
i don't want to be 40. i don't want to
you know get old but i don't want to die
at the same time i just got out of
college man
but uh yeah i don't know somebody
getting old just want to know your
thoughts on it love the podcast brother
keep it going game game
thanks corbin i appreciate you man uh
and yeah i appreciate the question um
[Music]
yeah getting old has always really
scared me
i feel like i'm running out of time to
learn
whatever lessons that i'm supposed to
learn or that the gods want me to learn
or
that my higher power you know that
that i'm not gonna have enough time to
learn certain things
your looks start disappearing that gets
dicey
that gets dicey dude
your nuts get longer when you gotta
reach for your nuts when you reach for
your nuts and you have to reach a little
bit
in a different place than you used to
reach
that's
that's a lot
for your hair i would say dude don't
pull out the gray hairs keep them in
because you can dye them later you'll
want that
if you pluck them then those hairs are
gone so then later if you don't have any
hair you're going to wish you'd never
plucked them just a note
it's a suggestion to you can do whatever
you want you could
damn cut your head off if you want
um
yeah getting old is always scary man my
father was so old
you know my father obviously i've
mentioned was 70 when i was born he was
70 years old so when i got to know him
he was 75 77
you know
about 80 by the time i kind of really
got a good look at him
and watching him move and watching him
be unable to do things
watching him rest
his eyes were always watering that's a
weird when old people water starts
coming out of them wherever it can
you know they'll have to pee or
something they'll fall asleep and
they'll just they'll cry for like 30
minutes while they're sleeping they'll
wake up and won't even have to pee
anymore
and they just you know
just their tear ducts was just damn
doing urine you know just crazy things
happen when you're old
you know they smell like milk start
smelling like milk like baby milk
um
yeah it's alarming man i think the thing
that gets the thing that i noticed from
me that makes it spookier is not filling
my life sometimes with things that make
you then feel young
i'll fill it with a lot of like worldly
stuff that makes me feel young
you know i date women at
all ages anywhere from probably
you know 40 to probably 25.
so sometimes you date a younger lady
makes you feel a little bit younger but
i'll stay young i'll play hoops with the
you know younger generations and stuff
like that
you know i'll listen to future i'll do
different [ __ ]
i'm an island boy
i'll listen to those freaking little
pineapple wiggers right there dude
jeepers come on what is that
um
but it's there's something about it that
stings man it's that
it's that the fact that you don't know
[Music]
you know the fact that you get but i i
you know
i think getting i think you want to make
sure you get to do the things you can do
while you're here that's what i think is
probably a bigger fear
that you get to love someone
that you get to apologize to somebody
that you get to forgive someone
um
that you get to take responsibility
that you get to maybe see your child
that you get to hug them or hold them
that you get to
[Music]
that you get to let somebody know how
much they mean to you
that you get to have real
real real human experiences
that those moments where when you're
when your mouth wants to say something
you don't say something that you that
you override those things
that you really push the pedal
on this experience of being human that's
that's one way to defeat some of that
aging feeling i think
i think people used to feel like this
was all there was in the existence realm
now
thanks to
i think just our own imaginations thanks
to times changing
uh
less ghosts i think people are moving on
and doing different things after they
die there's there's other experiences
and so i think people are more curious
about those
especially if we're living in a society
where maybe people aren't always making
the most out of all of the freaking uh
you know
out of all the stuff we got
but
and i don't mean to sound that in a in
like a dour way but i started noticing
for myself well i want to feel different
i want to have different feelings why i
need to have a different environment i
need to adjust what it is
and that means i need to have a family i
need to love someone i need to
be brave enough to do these things that
are going to make me feel alive
and that i think caleb
caller balances the aging
um
because yeah it's a little spooky
getting older man
and fighting to stay young is that oh
that's the worst
dude i went on a date with a gal and
i show she's what music we're playing in
the car and i give her my phone so
she's like you have eye music
she's like what are you like 60 and i
was i just felt so embarrassed
i should have done spotify
so little things like that you're afraid
to talk about movies like oh have you
seen this movie have you seen land
before time too
and you just see your date's face just
disappear
and it's just like just things like that
like
trying to stay young is very
hard it's also kind of fun though
trying to stay young
[Music]
but we're all chasing that moment of
just
when time was being older wasn't even a
thing there was no older
you were so just
all systems go man everything was just
like maybe 10 years old
when you thought about being across the
room and you were across the room
where you lie your friends would make
you laugh just like everything was so
free when you have to worry about there
was no concerns no worries
so to be that way again no matter what
age you are that is such a search i
think
to be that free
that age doesn't even
you don't even let it count you anymore
because you're such a g dog
because you such a damn bruce lee of
life
that when age comes to count you or cake
you up one year you say hey fam
you could do it but
you know i'm bigger than that
you know i'm doing something that
you can't calculate
and living in that kind of joy i think
there's a lot of value in that and this
but how do you get there i don't know
but that's one of the true journeys of
life that's why i always pains me when
people die young that they don't get to
try and see how things work and get to
have
the most out of this experience
um
but i don't know thank you for that
question man made me think all right
let's take one more call here
ceo
this is read from the great state of
louisiana
oh wow so really a lot of southern calls
from this episode let's we gotta let's
get some good calls from other places
too man portland i want to hear from you
guys australia
what do you guys are what are y'all
doing y'all home call
hit the hotline 985-664-9503
i'm not sure that two or three digit
code i think you might have to put in a
little bit
and i love y'all's autism show man god
god made me damn one australian autism
bro
people [ __ ] on that kind
let's hear it
i just listened to your podcast you're
wondering where everybody's from and
what they what they do for a living and
what scares them uh
i'm a crop duster so i fly
145 miles an hour about six feet off the
ground
it's a great time under power lines and
over trees
um
what scares me i'm afraid of spiders but
that really doesn't matter
uh
man love what you do
i always get a kick out of all your
podcasts and uh
even the podcast you do with that cte
fella so
love you man keep doing what you're
doing
thanks brother love you too man thanks
reed for the call man um
yeah dude you crop duster huh
wow
you out there you that hitman on them
bugs baby that real school shooter for
bugs
damn
you out there just taking care of those
soybeans corn cotton i'm guessing
i remember when i used to work on a
used to work out there near deer park in
vidalia louisiana on some of the corn
and
soy farms and
and sometimes we would get a crop duster
to come in and we go watch them be
pretty cool you know
nice change of pace from the day break
up the afternoon or whatever
um
yeah you should be scared of but look if
you're scared of spiders man i don't
blame you
those little things sneaky as hell man
especially look you sometimes you see
them videos at a funeral to climb out of
a damn eyeball or whatever they're crazy
bro spiders are they
you know the real fred astaire of the
insect kingdom too because they could
really
you put a right song on they'll [ __ ]
hit the beat boy eight legs
damn bro
you've seen a two-step what about that
eight step dawg
you know what i'm saying the damn day
dude they definitely the rick and morty
right out of their own pants brother
they can do anything they want really so
so i'm glad you're crop dusting i'm glad
you're killing them i'm glad you're
killing other bugs that are really doing
bad stuff out there
because i hate getting an apple i have
something a little worm a little
something little hole in it
a little damn uh
hornet or something stung it or just all
kind of [ __ ]
get a little ant up in your damn
strawberry or something
so i'm glad i'm glad knowing you out
there in airwaves risking your life
going under power lines
somebody's got to do it man i'm glad
you're doing it
i'm glad you're here with us while you
still are dude anything could happen to
you you guys a dangerous job you guys
have
you know really it's a really
you guys get euthanized all the time by
the by the power like you know you guys
get really shut down by god
a lot so
stay safe out there man and keep killing
them insects baby gang
and actually we're having trouble
locating the uh
the call that came in to nominate the
single mom so
we are gonna postpone it uh we'll do it
next time on the next solo episode all
right so yeah we'll get to that next
time and um
thank you guys for
[Music]
uh being a part of my life i hope you
guys are being good to yourselves
you deserve it i'm feeling a little bit
exhausted right now so i'm going to shut
it down um
and take a nap or do something to uh
to help alleviate some
you know i just feel uh
yeah i just get overrun by like these
stressful feelings and so sometimes i
just have to shut it down um so that's
what i'm going to do on the way out i'm
going to listen to a song that i've
really come to love and
and this guy just captures uh
you know he i've never had music that
really just uh spoke to me just spoke
was like saying words that i always
wanted to be able to say and and just
couldn't and uh
and this man does it dude it's a white
guy
and um
[Music]
and yeah we're gonna go out on this
uh
gang gang baby if you're upstairs stay
there and uh
and i'll see you there
uh in the future and i'll see you guys
in charleston and asheville
uh this weekend
and um
that's it
thank you very much if you need the
hotline if you're struggling with
something
985-664-9503 it's always open and uh
love you gang
[Music]
i won't call so you won't answer we
won't talk the way we used to
in my mind i'm back
[Music]
seems so much fun
when in your mind
[Music]
you're all alone
there's something in my head in my heart
a part of me that always hurts
on my own i tend to fall apart
am i
more than you bargainful
[Music]
man that's a hitter baby
you don't have to say yourself
if it's too hard for you to love me
when i get stuck in this condition you
try to help i try to listen
the land is over into my darkness your
heart breaks and i feel hopeless it's
not your fault if i care hold up
a part of me
that always
am i more
[Applause]
but am i more
[Music]
mmm
yeah man you can go get that hitter
right there that's evan bartell's
lonesome
is that song and
um
yeah if that song hit you some type of
way let me know about it man
then i think
that's the muhammad ali of my damn
feelings bro
um
praise god man i'll see you guys in the
future baby
uh
gang